uh be resolved now the mystery deepens
after the administration missed a
congressional deadline to declassify all
these documents on the virus started
that deadline was yesterday Jamie that's
a former World Health Organization
expert Committee Member uh back with us
and good morning to you
doesn't it seem a little strange how you
missed the deadline a day before
blinken's there meeting regi or did some
intent strike you with that I don't know
if there's intent the deadline was
yesterday Sunday which was a day off
today's a Federal holiday if by the
close of business tomorrow Tuesday
nothing is out in in the public I think
that's when we should really say that
that something is something is wrong but
if you really meant it maybe you don't
even wait till the deadline hits on
Sunday maybe do it Friday before the
week yeah it could be it could it could
be and the administration is trying to
balance a lot of things as as you know
Bill and Dana I've been very vocal on
the covet Origins issue I think we need
to be raising this front and center 20
million people are dead from a totally
avoidable pandemic and that's got to be
a big issue for us what do you think
about the reports from last week that
these three scientists from the lab are
the ones that first contracted it and
that that's how this all got going that
China tried to cover it up like do we
how much closer are we to knowing for
sure that it came from the lab well we
certainly from day one I have thought
that a research related origin was by
far the most likely way that this that
this pandemic started there are these
allegations apparently coming from
inside of the United States government
that the first three people infected
with the SARS cov2 virus were these
three named workers researchers in the
lab of shujangli at the Wuhan Institute
of virology if underlined if if that
should be proven that is 100 proof that
covid-19 comes from a lab accident then
it's really game over and then we shift
to what do we do about it how possible
is it that this Administration gives
China a pass on well we don't know I
mean I think that they are going to try
to push the administration President
Biden called for the intelligence review
by all the intelligence agencies that
had not happened under the previous
administration now we're reaching toward
declassification so I don't think that
there's some kind of internal cover-up I
don't think our government knows
something and is suppressing it but the
United States government is trying to
balance a lot of interest on Ukraine on
South China Sea on Taiwan on Chip's
economy all these other things and so
it's up to anyways up to us on the
outside who've been pushing so hard for
three and a half years to lay out the
evidence and say hey this is a really
important issue um I agree with you on
your list it's all important stuff yeah
so is the covet yeah so was the pandemic
yes it changed our lives yeah and we
spent a ton of money it's unbelievable
20 million people dead
trillions of dollars of economic losses
that's why I've said from day one we
need to fearlessly follow this evidence
wherever it leads and it's because it's
still happening I mean this is the Wall
Street Journal editorial board from the
weekend the main coveted lockdown
casualties children and suicide and
homicide rates for young people hit a
20-year high as political leaders
obsessed over protecting children from a
virus that presented little risk to the
young they ignored far bigger dangerous
so this is it's not like it's over
because it still is continuing and
there's economic impact but the issues
for children are really Stark this was
just an incredible trauma for everybody
in so many different ways there's the
origins issues there are very legitimate
debates to be had about our response
here in the United States and around the
world and that's why as I was saying
before we just need to be Fearless yes
it's politically sensitive to raise
these issues with China it's politically
sensitive to ask ourselves whether we
did the the right thing in the in the
early days but we have to do it because
we are entering a new age of synthetic
biology there will be additional threats
there will be additional pandemics if we
don't learn the lessons of what went
wrong we're going to face even greater
challenges in the future okay Jamie
thanks for coming in we missed the
deadline but we're still watching the
clock let's watch on Tuesday if it close
of business Tuesday we don't have
anything then we should start banging
pots and events thank you Jamie good to
have you I'm Steve juicy I'm Brian
Kilmeade and I'm Ainsley Earhart and
click here to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page to catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis